let's talk about ethics and lobbying
remember the phrase drain the swamp I
still sort of remember it as a campaign
promise although clearly it's not
happening now president Donald Trump has
exempted his entire senior staff from
his own ethics rules to allow them to
work with political and advocacy groups
that are supportive of his own
administration staffers have been given
a pass on these rules including the
infamous Kellyanne Conway who has been
greenlit to communicate and meet with
political advocacy trade or nor
nonprofit organizations that formerly
employed her own consulting firm
despite ethics rules that would
otherwise prevent her from working with
them chief White House strategist and
propagandist Steve vannin has been
waived from the rules so that he is
going to be able to communicate directly
with the press and do all sorts of other
stuff that Trump claimed he would not
allow staffers to do three former
lobbyists in the White House and one on
the vice president's staff have been
exempted from the so-called revolving
door rules imposed by Trump's I guess
we're calling it like an ethics
executive order which will now allow
those staffers to work on administration
policies that might benefit former
clients of theirs the White House waived
the rule for for example Trump energy
policy adviser Michael Catanzaro who's a
former lobbyist for oil and gas he was
given approval to work on energy and
environmental policy issues including
the clean power plan former oil and gas
lobbyist becomes part of Trump's
administration waived out of having to
abide by Trump's own ethics rules and
now can work on energy related issues
another example
tax policy adviser shahira Knight a
former executive of fidelity approved to
deal with tax retirement and financial
services issues even though she used to
be a lobbyist on those topics
this is bottom-of-the-barrel
the level of going backwards on the
promises first of all if you don't
really plan on actually having
strict ethics rules maybe don't campaign
on it Trump campaigns on it
he passes these sort of half-hearted
executive orders to sort of fulfill the
campaign promise
but then issues a waiver to all of his
top campaign staff so what's the point
of rules if people are waved out of
having to abide by the rules yeah that's
the thing this was half-hearted to begin
with because of course most of the
corruption occurs in the legislative
branch of government the this executive
order only applied to the executive
branch of government you have to go
after things like campaign finance
reform overturning Citizens United maybe
even term limits but I think he's
already checked off the box as if he's
drained the swamp
oh yeah no this is okay as far as Trump
is concerned hey he passed the rules and
that's it he's done is his whole ethics
thing and even further supporting the
smoke and mirrors thing is what you're
pointing out Pat which is that these
lobbyists can still go back in or these
former government officials can still go
back and lobby Congress if not the
executive branch this is beyond the pale
and the problem we're running up against
is that there's so much happening so
quickly every single day it's tough to
to keep up with it for the average
person I mean just in the last few days
we've got you know Jeff Sessions and
Kitt's Lee acts new undisclosed meeting
Donald Trump giving back Russian
compounds in New York and Maryland that
one's house presumably spies Trump and
the Paris climate agreement now this
slimy corrupt move regarding the ethics
rules and this is a tactic in in a
debate have you heard of the dish Gallup
Pat yes so in a debate dish Gallup is
you fill up your 90 seconds or whatever
you have with so many disjointed
arguments that your opponent is never
going to be able to refute all of them
in the 90 seconds that they have and it
sort of appears as though hey you made
all these points but nobody refuted this
is a similar version of that which is
you throw out and do such a barrage of
BS that everybody is drowned by it and
people end up either ignoring it or
focusing on one or two things and
ignoring really really major major
stories this is sort of the tactic that
the Trump administration is relying on
this is the only way they can get things
done yeah it's really too bad because we
thought that government ethics reform
might be one of the saving graces of the
Trump administration of course we
we disagree with him on 90% of issues
but maybe this is the one thing that we
could find consensus on with him well
even more so than Hillary Clinton we
agreed with the campaign promise of
course he passed a milquetoast version
of it and then waived his own senior
staff out of it
yeah I don't think we can pat ourselves
on the back too much but I think we were
wise enough to know that that wasn't
going to happen yeah and obviously it
really hasn't
what's next a pre-emptive pardon for any
crimes Trump may have or will be
committing in the future
III don't know who could possibly
support what Trump is doing by waving
out his senior staff and his own ethics
rules if you supported draining the
swamp if for a second you believed Trump
would drain swamp how could you possibly
see this and say I support the actions
of Donald Trump